hello
my name is greg cooligan and i'm an
architect with the apogee team at google
cloud
very excited to be here today with my
friend and colleague deborah elkin
who will join us a little later on to
give us an amazing demo of some of this
functionality that we talk about today
so let's get into it i'm not going to
read this agenda slide
but there's a key takeaway how you can
use anthos and apogee as it means for
deploying secure apis
while allowing developers to focus on
delivering business value
let's set this up just a little bit at
my company there's an app innovation day
i built a killer app
jelly bean auto count we all want to win
jelly bean guessing contests
the app i built utilized some sick
machine learning models to quickly and
accurately provide account of the jelly
beans in any jar just by processing a
photo
everyone agreed that this app was
amazing and we needed to make it
available to all our employees
i've got this great code but how should
i deploy it
i went to my colleague maria as i knew
she was a wizard on our ops team
maria said i have just the thing we've
been doing kubernetes for a while now
and had learned that it was
difficult to manage multiple clusters
particularly across different regions
there was a new technology that the
company was trying called anthos
gke it promised to simplify management
of kubernetes
creating a consistent experience for
developers while doing so
securely sounded fantastic to me
so we went ahead and deployed my app to
kubernetes my app was pretty basic
but outside of following secure coding
practices i didn't have to concern
myself with security
scaling etc people loved the app
usage was through the roof i used this
as an opportunity to recruit some team
members
we were getting lots of enhancement
requests and began working through the
backlog
since our architecture was based on
microservices we saw
a proliferation of services we quickly
realized that we needed a way to help us
manage and secure all of these services
back to maria marie had an answer again
there's a reason i keep going to her in
this case we can use a service mesh
to help us secure the services
understand the interactions
and help us generally manage the traffic
the great news is that we have a fully
managed service mesh offering
already available as part of anthos
called anthos service mesh
this was again a great relief as we had
enough backlog to get through without
worrying about managing all of the tls
and certificates and
access control and routing and just all
of that junk
as you can see we simply layered in
antho service mesh and kept going on our
merry way
with just a little help from us the
operators on maria's team added all of
the policies into the antho service
mesh to secure the communication between
all of our services
all of a sudden other teams in the
enterprise caught wind and wanted access
to these services we were building
before now it was just a couple of us
and we all worked very closely together
we wanted to let other teams use our
services but we didn't want to take a
bunch of
our time onboarding these teams back to
maria
i'm sure no one is surprised to learn
that she had another solution
this time apogee hybrid it runs on top
of anthon's gke
and the runtime can be co-located with
our services it provides a way for us to
make our documentation discoverable
and allow internal teams to gain access
to our apis via self-service
no need to talk to anyone on my team so
as you can see
we layered an apg to help manage these
apis that we were exposing to other
teams
more success at this point teresa one of
the execs took notice
she saw the popularity of this app and
knew we had to make it available to
external developers
turns out we already had all of the
pieces in place to make that happen
we simply needed to add a few more
apogee capabilities such as threat
protection
rate limiting and oidc we also needed to
ensure that we could handle the load
we simply deployed another cluster of
gke and apg hybrid
in gcp to ensure that we could scale
so that's all great but as i stated i'm
just a developer that wants to deliver
business value
i know anything about exposing apis to
third parties how could this be made as
simple as possible for me
with that i'm going to turn things over
to deborah to walk us through how we
might
how we might be able to enable someone
like me
thanks greg let's explore this with the
demo
in the demo we will see how we can
leverage cicd pipelines to make it very
easy to expose
services through secure apis
it is standard practice when working
with services to use
ci cd pipelines to automatically build
and deploy whenever changes are
committed this
not only increases developer
productivity and software quality
but also makes it easy to ensure best
practices are followed when developing
services
in the demo the cicd pipeline is
governed by cloud build
when new code is checked into a
repository managed by cloud source
repositories
cloud field triggers a new build this
will generate
a new container image check it into
cloud container registry and deploy this
container
into a service cluster we can use
a similar approach for making it very
easy to build an api to front
service when the service developer tags
the source code
cloud builder will orchestrate the
generation of a new api
proxy and deployed to an apigee hybrid
runtime
cloud builder will test the api is
successfully working
and check the newly generated api
configuration back into cloud source
repository
even without having a deep knowledge of
api development
a service developer can easily generate
an api
that incorporates the best practices
adopted by the company
once the api is deployed clients can
access this api
all external access is mediated by
apigee
providing a secure layer and eliminating
the need to expose the service cluster
externally the demo we are going to see
is from the point of view of a service
developer
well first in software development but
not necessarily an expert in api
management
cloud source repository is used for code
source control
typically the developer will also use a
local editor
on their workstation to work on the
source code
check to their local repository and push
the changes to the remote
repository cloud container registry is
used to store
all the container images that are
generated during the development process
the services are deployed to an enthos
asm cluster
in this case it is a development cluster
additionally there's another gke cluster
in which an instance of
apigee hybrid runtime has been deployed
let's have a look in cloud source
repository
in mature teams the structure of the
repository is generated automatically
when project is created and it follows
templates that encourage best practices
in
software development it even enforces
them some time
a very common practice is to have ci cd
pipelines
that is continuous integration continued
development pipelines
that are triggered when code is checked
the pipeline triggers the build of a new
container image and deployment of this
newly built
image into a service cluster
let's see this in action the developer
will work on their local
visual editor they will make changes
to their code and once they're ready
they will commit it to their local
repository
they will then push those changes to the
remote
repository
when the changes reach the remote
repository
a new build is started this is managed
by cloud build
let's have a look at what happens during
the build
the first step builds the new container
image
it then pushes it to container registry
after that it is deployed to the anthos
cluster
the last step verifies that all the
artifacts have been deployed and that
they are successfully working
let's go back to cloud source
repositories and have a look in more
detail
to the structure of the repository
we can see that there is an api folder
in there there is a readme file that
explains these steps
necessary to expose this service as an
apigee
api namely we need to provide a couple
of
api configuration data and also
type the repository that's all the
developer needs to know
in order to expose the service as an api
the developer decides to go ahead and do
this
so once again we switch to the local
editor and edit the configuration for
the api
we need to provide a proxy based path
this is where the
api will be reachable and we also need
to provide
the backend it will be connected to in
our case our hello world service
once again the developer commits their
changes
pushes the changes to the remote
repository
create a new tag
and finally pushes the changes including
the new tag
to the remote repository
once again this triggers another
pipeline that is managed by cloud build
this pipeline in its first step
generates
an apigee api proxy based on a template
it then deploys this api into the apigee
environment
and also generates all the associated
artifacts required for the api to run
it also shows an api key that is
required in order to test
this api
the next step tests that the api has
been successfully deployed
it is actually in both a couple of very
simple requests
one one without an api key and the other
one
with an api key
the next few steps check the code
generated for the api back into the
source code repository
it is worth mentioning that the api
that's generated
incorporates all the best practices that
a centralized api
team deemed as necessary for instance
verifying api
keys checking for threads etc
typically this centralized api team will
be in charge of managing the templates
used and will continually update them
with best practices
as their security posture changes
let's now take a look under the hood and
explore what the api
does for that we will switch to the
apigee user interface
when we look at the api proxies that
have been defined
we can see that now we have a new one
related to our hello service
when we look into the details of the
proxy we can see that it is
connected to our hello service which is
available on the hello endpoint
in the anthous cluster ingress let's
have a look at the policies implemented
by
this proxy remember that these have all
been
order generated so first it will add a
correlation id to the request
if one doesn't exist if one exists
it'll just make sure to remember it so
that it can inject it back in
in the response it will then apply some
threat protection policies to ensure
that no attacks are sent in the headers
for instance
it will then verify that an api key
is provided and that it is valid it will
then enforce
quota limits on the number of calls and
finally
we'll apply json thread protection
policies
on the payload of the api
if all the checks pass successfully it
will forward the request to our hello
world service
on the way back it will inject a
correlation id
if the hello world service didn't
preserve the one that was
sent in the request
let's now see the api in action in order
to do
that we will start a very handy feature
that
apigee has that allows you to trace
every request that comes into the api
proxy for that we'll use some
pre-prepared requests that we have
the first one sends a request without an
api key
as expected we get a 401 unauthorized
response
because there was no api key included in
the request
our second test doesn't include an api
key
either but it does include a malicious
header
let's test it out
as expected we get an error because the
api has detected a thread
in one of the headers
our next test it's a valid request
it is a request that does include an api
key
as expected we get a successful response
and by the way this is the new version
of the service
that was deployed at the beginning of
the demo
it also includes includes a correlation
id
that was automatically generated because
our request didn't include one
our next test does include a correlation
id in the request when we execute it
we can see that the response does
include that correlation id
played back
let's now send a few more requests
if we send them a quick succession
we will at some point hit a quarter
limit
and that's when the api will return an
error
let's see how apigee handled all of
these requests
the first one it's the one that returned
the 401 that's when we didn't have an
api
key the verify api key policy
failed in this case and stopped any
further processing
the second case is when the thread
protections failed
again all for the processing is stopped
the next few requests are the ones that
were successful
we can see that all of the policies were
successfully
executed and then the request was sent
to the target server
when the response was received it was
forwarded back
to the client revoking the api
including the newly generated
correlation id
the last request it's the one that
failed
because we had exceeded our quarter
limit and again
any further processing was stopped
in this demo we have seen modern
software development practices that are
commonly adopted by the developer
community when building services
such as cicd and we have also seen how
we can leverage these practices to
easily solve the problem of exposing
these services to external consumers in
a secure way
the service developer does not need to
be an api guru in order to build apis
that incorporate all of the required
best practices
i hope you have enjoyed the demo thank
you for watching it
thanks deborah that all made good sense
and i think it's something even i could
understand
but i have a question when do you
generally see customers
set something like this up well
generally customers with larger
enterprises and mature programs
are the ones who set this up in order to
enable a truly federated model
by that i mean a model in which api
creation is not concentrated in a small
team of
api experts but rather distributed all
along the developer community
okay got it but we all know that
security requirements are going to
evolve
sometimes quite quickly how do teams
manage the security of their apis across
these distributed areas
that's when we generally see a
centralized team that is responsible
not just for the creation of these
automated templates
but also of the shared flows that they
use with the shared flow you can build
reusable units of logic that are
invoked by the apis in mature
organizations
security measures are normally
implemented using shared flows
if the centralized team sees the need to
update some of these
security measures they will update the
shared flow
all apis making use of this shared flow
will automatically apply the latest and
greatest security measures
yeah okay i think that's a good plan
so with that i think it's time to wrap
up today
we talked about how you can use anthos
and apogee hybrid together
to secure apis with debra's demo you can
see how easy it was for a developer to
expose an api
using best practices set up for them by
an api center for enablement or similar
team
allowing the developer to concentrate on
delivering business value
i want to thank you for watching this
session and offer to continue the
conversation
both deborah and i have set up some
expert one-on-one sessions over the next
couple of weeks
we will also be answering your questions
in the question and answer section for
this session